die kühlschrank kaufen
wir brauchen eine einkaufsliste haben
wir orangensaft haben wir alle gibt's
noch butter
wie ist es mit milch
ist auch alle und marmelade ich fast
alle unsere einkaufsliste ist fertig wir
gehen jetzt in den supermarkt wir sind
jetzt im supermarkt wieder pausen ein
das ist ein einkaufswagen oder nimmt den
einkaufswagen im blatt nimmt den
einkaufskorb
das ist ein einkaufskorb wo ich die
milch rocken sucht die milch oder hat
die milch gefunden
oder hat die mutter gefunden
ambler suchte brot aus gut auf die
gruppe hat jetzt alles wie gehen zur
kasse hallo baby molly bar oder mit
karte
braucht ihr eine tüte ich brauche wenig
das macht dann bereits ein euro führte
[Musik]
dankeschön
und zurück das war unsere episode über
das einkaufen aus der hyperbaren herum
ganz cooler susanne ist deutschlehrerin
hier und hat uns an diese schule in
norwegen eingeladen wenn ihr uns auch
mal einladen möchte schreibt uns einfach
den link ist hier unten
danke für eure einladung bitteschön
[Musik]